[Music]
the first commercially successful
digital camera with a
natashia camera when that came I really
realized together with the cell phone
it becomes the poet of the 21st century
[Music]
link generator know something in the
email Authenticator I think it was a day
like any of the other days she was late
[Music]
[Music]
it's one of the few occurrences where
you have a chance to speed and not be
stopped
[Music]
license and registration please
so I explained to the officer that we
were going to labor the officer was
funny he said I heard that line before
this is 1997 the maternity doesn't have
Wi-Fi doesn't exist yet if I wanted to
share pictures instantly I need to be
able to to talk to this phone physically
and then use this Eureka moment how's it
going don't have the right cable give
your soldering iron one down two flights
of stairs and basically ripped up the
fall speakerphone from the car
[Music]
I had a laptop on a on a desk that was
next to the the c-section operating
table had a long wire that connected the
camera to it and a laptop was connected
to the server that was my kitchen I'm
holding the baby in my left hand and I'm
holding the camera in the other one it
went out to about 2,000 people friends
and family and business connection point
shoot and share instantly I start
getting emails how do you do that the
date says that your daughter was born
like 15 minutes ago and I just got that
97 on that day June 11 1997 there were
two birds and most important was my
daughter Sophie obviously and the camera
phone there's a very profound impact of
instant imagery and sharing imagery that
is going to change society and the way
people evolve
[Music]
[Music]